en milieu d'après-midi la bataille
d'irpine a bel et bien commencé
impossible d'aller plus loin l'armée
russe bombarde massivement
un déluge de feu s'abat sur cette ville
stratégique à une quinzaine de
kilomètres de Kiev
des explosions quasiment permanentes
les soldats Ukrainiens reviennent du
front sans un mot
l'air exténué
ce groupe de jeunes volontaires alertent
on est venu secourir les gens mais notre
voiture est bloquée de l'autre côté
c'est à part la voiture il y a quelque
chose d'important mais pour rejoindre la
voiture il faut s'approcher encore de la
zone d'affrontement ok nous voyons ok
vous y allez tous les deux et avec Olga
aussi
je vais enlever mon
ces jeunes vont devoir risquer leur vie
pour aller chercher leur voiture
toi aussi tu vas l'enlever
ce matin quelques centaines de mètres
plus loin
les civils fuient la ville dans un calme
encore relatif
un exode à travers ce pont détruit
quelques heures plus tard
les combats se rapprochent à ces moments
de la folie ce qui se passe ici de la
folie
des obus tombent dans tous les sens les
Russes essayent de prendre cette ville
pour ensuite aller directement sur keV
les habitants continuent à être évacués
moins nombreux que le matin mais dans un
contexte autrement plus dangereux
cette ambulance revient chargé de
déplacer
ne vous poussez pas les uns les autres
doucement des personnes âgées
des familles et des enfants est-ce que
vous pouvez vous arrêter à Bellucci
oui on va s'arrêter là bas
entrez tous là les enfants d'abord
à l'intérieur du bus des slogans de
gloire à l'Ukraine
grâce à Dieu merci pour ce bus pour ce
trajet que Dieu soit avec nous
et un immense soulagement pour ses
dizaines de personnes qui sortent de
l'enfer
la bataille d'irpine n'a pas livré son
dernier mot mais les Russes semblent
bien décidé à s'en emparer
quel qu'en soit le prix